Hello, I'm Seerajperhead.
I'm a program manager at Udacity, and
this is my bad interview experience.
So, after three years
of engineering college,
I really wanted to intern at this
one tech company in Cupertino.
I spent all year preparing for this and
I knew that this was the company
I wanted to work for.
I nailed my first interview and
then got into the second interview
which was a tech screen
with one of their teams.
And I completely failed it.
I don't even remember the questions.
I don't remember if I was dizzy or
tired or
sleepy or what, or
just unqualified I guess.
But that interview was terrible.
I spent about two weeks
like depressed about it,
thinking about like that it's time for
me to move on.
And find like a different
company I'd be interested in.
Surprisingly the recruiter
called me back.
And that while I didn't make their
one position, they wanted me for
a different one.
So I agreed, and happily took another
interview which I also failed.
At that point I realized that maybe
I wasn't cut out to be an engineer
at their company.
And I decided that I would
look at other companies and
finally move on from these dreams.
But then the recruiter
messaged me again and said,
Sia, while you're not cut out for one of
our engineering positions the summer,
would you like to have
a product interview?
And I didn't know much about products,
but I was like, sure.
This is the company.
This must be it.
Whatever.
Let's do this.
And that interview went amazing.
Looking back at that summer, I realize
that the product role was a much better
fit for me than any engineering role
could have been at that company.
So my takeaway from this is that
sometimes interviews don't go the way
you want them to,
and sometimes job positions don't enough
the way that you think they will.
Don't stress too much about a bad
interview, because in the end,
it just becomes a funny
story to tell your friends.